[Music]
will smith finally apologize
and marsh
i'm warning you right now
because you know how he gets when he
becomes emotional will smith i'm gonna
get mad this is very cringy okay this is
very you could tell he's acting we're
not gonna get haha
no no no no you're gonna get you're
gonna get
[ __ ]
the movie when you got aids
[Laughter]
yeah you know what you're trying to talk
about pursuit of happiness oh you're
gonna get the pursuit of happiness will
smith there we go you ready here you go
why didn't you apologize to chris in
your acceptance speech
is that how he reads yeah
he reads like [ __ ] i feel like lebron
james is reading this um
i was fogged out by that point
it's it's it's it's all fuzzy i've
reached out to
chris um
and the mesh the message that came back
is that he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out
um
so i will i will say to you
chris i
apologize
to you
seems sincere
right
so far it's okay
my behavior was
unacceptable
and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk
um
i want to apologize isn't it amazing to
see two hollywood people act like drama
streamers with each other it really is
it's so weird right
he's to
chris's mother oh i saw an interview
that chris's mother did
and
you know that i want to apologize to
chris's mother
because i didn't say goodbye afterward
clap that ass yo chris i don't know yo
chris i don't apologize for [ __ ] dog
apologize the whole family comes out
behind you yeah out of the box [ __ ]
getting jiggy with it starts playing in
the background i don't apologize for
[ __ ] dog
they're all coming out everyone comes
out except jada you don't think netflix
will give me a hundred mil right now to
make a bunch of shitty movies like adam
sandler are you [ __ ] crazy chris i
bet i could get netflix to give me 200
million just to get a [ __ ] footage of
me smacking you in the mouth again
i'm gonna make a new show i'm gonna make
a new show for netflix called me
slapping that [ __ ] chris rock in the
mouth it's gonna be five seasons 13 at
one hour episodes and every episode it's
gonna be slapping your [ __ ] mouth
what was the [ __ ] nick cage movie
that's coming out
of a [ __ ] i don't know the name the
unbearable weight of massive talent yeah
yeah yeah that one it's like i'm gonna
call this
uh
the unusual easiness of smacking
christmas chris rock in his mouth
i'm not gonna apologize to you are you
kidding me
in fact i'm gonna re i'm reuniting with
martin lawrence for bad boys four and uh
we're both of us are gonna smack you in
the mouth
[Laughter]
we're gonna call it bad boys bad boys
five
bad boys five
the hunt for that [ __ ] chris rock's
mouth
and that's a michael bay movie so even
if you don't want to be a part of the
movie we'll just [ __ ] cgi that [ __ ]
you're gonna be bumblebee in that [ __ ]
uh but what he actually said was was one
of the things about that moment i just
didn't realize
and you know i wasn't thinking but how
many people got hurt in that moment
so i want to apologize to chris's mother
i want to apologize to
chris's family
specifically tony rock you know we had a
great relationship
you know
until your little bitch-ass son opened
his mouth about my wife
hey by the way chris i'll slap your
daddy in the mouth too
that's his brother oh sorry i'll slap
your brother in the mouth too
iraq
was my man um
and uh this is this is probably
irreparable
um
so irreparable that i still have to have
a box of my water sponsor on the table
well i mean you got it
right it's you know if you're going to
do a show you got to promote the
sponsors it's part of your contract
right
i spent the last
three months
um replaying
and
being in cabo
you know it's hard on my mega yacht you
know what i mean it was real tough it is
hard though it must be difficult
understanding the nuances and and the
complexities of what happened
in what is your response not really
there's not nuance and complexities in
it you smack the man in the mouth on
national television i feel like if
anything
it isn't nuanced it's that yeah i've
seen enough body cam footage to know
this happens a lot like this isn't
something new or groundbreaking you were
just a real [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
turns out that black men smacking each
other in the mouth is not really a
groundbreaking moment or a nuanced
moment no
no
in that moment
um
and
i'm not gonna try to unpack all of that
right now he's also wearing a hat that
you could buy that's his specific brand
well you know again
but i can say to i thought it was just
promoting westworld
yeah because this [ __ ] apology's
robotic
all of you i want to apologize now have
a drink with me partner yeah [ __ ]
evan rachel wood is a less wooden
actress yeah [ __ ] seriously
there is no although she's probably
[ __ ] more women
it's
part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
in that moment
there's no part of me that thinks that's
the optimal way to
handle
a feeling of disrespect or or insults
a joke see he's still doing it though
hold on
did you see what he did yeah a feeling
of disrespect
or insult
go [ __ ] yourself
all right go [ __ ] yourself
it was a joke what you should have said
after a joke because he made fun of a
lot of other people too and i took it
personal everyone took it in stride now
get ready for this next one this is him
this is him if you believe it this is
what you're about to see
is jada saying you better [ __ ] go out
there not say put this [ __ ] on blame me
for this watch
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something
you don't think jada made sure that this
question was the one that was read it's
just jada wrote this question now let's
see what he says
no
um
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own look at this like a prisoner
well look man i think you're an [ __ ]
for slapping it but still as a dude i
gotta say man you're with me here right
marcia as a dude i gotta say bro
she's broken you man she [ __ ] broke
you dude and you need to get out of this
quickly because now before you know
you're going to be stabbing somebody
next for her and she'll convince you
that it was all your idea
right like i told him not to stab that
man
from my own experiences from
my history with chris jada had nothing
to do with it
nothing my history with chris meaning
that you had a problem with him before
sorry babe
um
and say sorry to my my kids and i'm
sorry babe he's apologizing to
she made him apologize to her and
anybody that doesn't see that is insane
to me
right this is i'm not just making this
up right you're seeing i know it's also
because we we've been covering this
since before people were calling this
out mercia and i were [ __ ] watching
their instagram video remember that or
that little facebook video that they
made where he was [ __ ] pissed and i'm
like we were both like man this is
something going on here there's
something bad underneath here and now we
know it's her
and he just apologized to her
this is not great
and my family
for the heat that i brought on
all of us
um to all my
fellow nominees
you know this is a community it's like i
won because you you voted for me and it
it really breaks my heart to have stolen
and and harnessed tarnished
your moment
um
you know it's probably even more pissed
the runner up for that academy award
probably i can still see i i would have
taken the award and not punched anybody
in the face exactly right i mean
i feel like that's i feel like that's
pretty easy right yeah
quest loves
eyes you know it it happened on quest
love's
uh award and
you know
it's like i'm i'm
i'm sorry really isn't
sufficient
but it's not jada's fault though i want
to really
the big takeaway from this
i really want people to realize
this was not in any way jada's fault
what would you say to the people who
looked up to you
before the slap or people who expressed
that you let them down
um
so there's two things one
um
disappointing people is my central
trauma
what
ah more therapy talk yeah more l.a
therapy talk
i love it
um i hate
when
i let people down
so then what was after earth about
[Laughter]
it
it hurts
it hurts me psychologically and
emotionally to know i didn't live up to
uh people's
image and impression of me
and
i know right the work i'm trying to do
it's so hard being will smith
it's so hard being will smith right it
must be so difficult shut the [ __ ] up
all right i think i mean we i could
watch more if you want it's really i
think it's pretty much that's you get
the gist of it
uh you know i don't know if
really the rest has anything worth value
i mean he already apologized to jada
which i thought was just the cringiest
part which is the most important
takeaway is that now we know jada had
nothing to do with this she's not a
toxic force in his life at all